cet enfant découvre la justice pour lui
de ol est auspert elle est mystérieuse
cet îlot moins qu'il y a quinze ans un
jour de septembre un jour de rentrée
scolaire un président et un garde des
sceaux ont plaidé pour l'abolition de la
peine de mort le garde des sceaux
demande l'abolition sans amendement ni
réserve
c'est l'honneur au nom du gouvernement
de la république de demander à
l'assemblée nationale
l'abolition de la peine de mort en
france au début des années 80 claude
genre d'un magistrat du parquet était à
la chancellerie pour lui les années
mitterrand se sont aussi vu les années
pas d'un plein foisonnement une
ouverture densité de réflexion serré
autour de deux normes protée de nantes
clé mais comme je me suis mitterrand
choisit qui a été long
quelle justice au moins pendant le
premier septennat sts dit robert
badinter un couple mitterrand badinter
qui scellera la disparition des
tribunaux d'exception abrogera la loi
sécurité et liberté dans le permis et la
loi anti casseur de michel poniatowski
et relancera la réforme du code pénal
mais magistrats et avocats
attendons le président sur
l'indépendance des juges
quelles que soient les critiques qu'ont
pu faire les juges au moment des
affaires et cetera les juges chanson
sortie finalement plus fort
les juges en sont sorties plus
indépendants sans doute qu'il ne l'était
en 1981 et là je suis bien obligé de
constater tout le monde est obligé de
constater que ça c'est peut-être ça qui
était la volonté profonde du président
même si ça s'est fait un peu contre lui
lors du premier septennat myriam ezratty
était directrice de l'administration
pénitentiaire pour l arrivée de françois
mitterrand c'est avant tout un
dépoussiérage de l'institution une
tentative de rendre la justice est plus
proche de la société
c'est une politique d'ouverture de dire
que la justice et pas seulement la
sphère des juges la sphère des services
spécialisés que ça concerne la société
françois mitterrand aurait pu rester
avocat il s'est tourné vers la politique
restant ainsi un homme de droit est un
homme de loi